that was weird so now we're walking in
the hallway going to the to the meeting
i'm sorry i gotta i was crying so i keep
do we have tissues
so uh
yeah thank you and um
so then we go to the meeting
and it's holly barrio and jeb you know
the president the vice president of
amelie and we're sitting there and the
same thing again they're like oh my god
steve
is
telling everybody to watch your special
and and everybody i just want you to
know everyone here at amblin is watching
special and uh we all love it we're huge
fans and
and i'm like
are we talking about the same steve like
you know what i mean like you just said
who's stephen let's get him in the room
can we get him in the room
and then he was just like yeah man mr
spielberg is a huge fan and
next thing you know like it was this
fast howie as fast as i'm talking to you
about what happened this is how it all
went down they go he wants to make a
movie with you so do you have an idea
what kind of idea do you have for a
movie did you have an idea i did i had a
deal with uh ride back dan lin right
right back
right back ranch and um and i pitched a
movie to them called easter sunday which
is
the the holiday that filipinos love we
do it's our favorite holiday that's when
the family comes together and uh but i
told him it's it's it's it's it's family
it's love it's comedy it's chaos all in
one day on easter sunday basically right
right and um
and you know there's more to it than
that but dan lynn was actually you know
we were trying to find a writer with dan
lynn and dan lane by the way did uh it
won it to aladdin with uh will smith
like that's his those are his legos all
the lego movies are his so you know he's
no he's amazing to be like a spielberg
yeah he's a spielberg
yeah exactly so
uh i look at joe and i go uh can i pitch
that thing he goes well we don't have a
we don't have a contract we didn't say
anything pitch it and i pitched easter
sunday to them and they bought it in the
room they're like we'll take it i want
that movie spielberg wants that movie
let's do it and uh and we i go what
about dan lynn they go we'll call him if
he wants to join he'll join if not
that's cool we're doing it it was that
fast
we even went to lunch and this is why i
always say this
celebrate every moment
right because people like we live in a
time now where everything's so fast
right and you want it now and if it's
not now then we can't celebrate right
right and that's that what is living
like why you're not even living at this
point like
like like when we left the the office
like we're hugging each other and we
both got emotional duh i cried and then
um
and joe was like well we'll see
what are you talking about we'll see
there's nothing else to see like this
was an amazing moment you know how many
people wished steven spielberg watched
their tape or even looked at their
headshot or gave a call like bro
celebrate this moment
like even if nothing happens four months
from now who gives a [ __ ] this moment is
this is an amazing moment and we get to
and we get to say it
and um so we got into a little fight we
even went to lunch and got into another
fight like dude stop like and he was oh
i'm just saying i know how hollywood is
i'm like stop
celebrate the moment let's eat and let's
enjoy this moment that we just had
and then right right when i said that
boom he gets a phone call from holly and
she's like yep just talk to dan we're
moving forward he's joining the team it
was that fast and who who wrote it
uh we got we got a bunch of uh writers
to write it and then we got my favorite
is uh jay chandrasekhar who uh
is you know he did all the he's broken
lizard he does uh all the super troopers
and all that stuff but uh also the
goldbergs he shoots that
and he came in and uh
and just took over and and directed the
movie for me so and you shot it we shot
it we it and then what was crazy is the
pandemic happened and i thought for sure
wasn't gonna happen i thought it was
done
and uh and then they got the call i got
the call they're like uh april we're
moving we're going we're going to
vancouver to shoot this movie and i was
like oh my god so this past april you
were there we just shot it yeah and i
just got back
and when is it coming out
uh easter sunday 2022. and he wants a
theatrical release he doesn't want a
screaming release he wants a full-blown
theatrical release
red carpet everything was that not an
amazing story it's amazing not only the
story it's amazing
i think the way that you view life is
amazing to me that was it to me that was
what i mean obviously to shoot a movie
and have that come out and everything
that's incredible steven spielberg oh
that's incredible but to me what i take
away from that is celebrating each and
every moment because i think that's
something i know i struggle with i've
seen you struggle with that a lot in
your business and your career where
you're like well we'll see i don't know
this happens all the time so i think
that that's a really important lesson to
take away from that because people who
think in another way and i sometimes do
with my ocd
it's also a protection yeah right so
the fear is if you celebrate that moment
and you're right if you celebrate that
moment yeah if that moment like joe
whoever was saying it to you if it
doesn't come to fruition yeah then
you're afraid of that disappointment
if i don't climb this high into my
emotions i don't have a long way to drop
but i also read that book like the power
of now yeah you know now is all we have
yeah what happened before is our
perception of it and memory and if there
were other people there they don't
remember it the exact same way and maybe
it didn't happen exactly the way you
remember it
what may happen in the future hasn't
happened yet the only thing that's real
is now the only thing we have is now
yeah and
that's those are words that i'm saying
and maybe somebody's listening to but
you live it yeah that's probably why
you are where you are like because
netflix said no to you first yeah so i'm
sure most people would be like well then
then no then it's no and i'm giving up
and you lived in the now and like no i'm
gonna make it i'm not thinking about
what's gonna happen later i'm doing it
now even if i made the decision to go
ahead and make it if i got that call
that you got
you know i just want to i want you to
know that we're just not interested yeah
that might have stopped me i know it
would have stopped most people
and the fact that you're able to go
through that what a great example you
are of humanity of perseverance of being
a father of being a friend these are
great this story that you just told i'm
so proud that you told that on here
because even the celebrating the moment
is what this is about and i'm looking at
people on the other side of the glass
and everybody was just
you know
what an amazing story it really is your
family has to be
more importantly so proud of you
so proud of uh what you do and how
you're and it just keeps going and going
and going what is next
[Music]